avec plaisir mélodies le château d'un
est classé monument historique depuis
bâtie de 15 147 à 15 152 sur les ordres
d'henri 2 pour sa favorite diane de
poitiers mais ça c'est la légende on en
parlera avec d'autres invités jean dollé
turbo bonjour vous êtes le propriétaire
mais avant d'en parler avec vous je vous
propose de voir que ce château est
encore méconnue de la part de beaucoup
de gens du centre val de loire regarder
château d'onet
je suis super nuit je suis une bille
angers ou alors j'en ai aucune idée
j'ai honte en bretagne un nouvel
aquitaine non à chatou d'annette
d'annette 37 noms tournons à ces dans la
région nombreux lots je tiens à lindre
ça me paraît loin mais en même temps ça
se rapproche des boîtiers de l'indre
château d'onet c'est dans seine-et-marne
je crois que c'est peut-être dans
l'eure-et-loir hulu par l'art c'est ça
du côté de rambouillet que je connais
pas le château jamais visité a bien sûr
dans l'eure et loir c'est que annette je
crois que c'est une ville un nom mais je
suis pas sur un oui à net c est une
ville est ce que ça vous étonne en
nantes en bretagne nouvelle aquitaine
seine-et-marne est ce que ça vous étonne
dans ça va être pas beaucoup parce que
annette n'est pas sur les grands
circuits touristiques
malheureusement j'aurais bien aimé sur
la loire mais diane de poitiers en a
décidé autrement et elle a fait son
château à chenonceau mais annette et et
la maison sur lequel elle a le plus vécu
pendant toute sa vie c'est un château en
privé c'est un château privé qui est
dans la famille depuis 1860 et qui a été
acheté par mon arrière grand père
arrière-arrière-grand-père pardon en
après la révolution après une période
qui a vu une partie du château démoli
beaucoup de changements et à partir de
1860 monmon trisaïeul se met à restaurer
la maison
eh bien on verra cela après pour ceux
qui n'ont pas eu cette chance de visiter
ce château parce qu'il faut prendre
rendez vous pour le visiter et bien je
vous propose deux pros
avec ce reportage regarder annette or
est inspirée versailles construit à la
moitié du xvième siècle annette c'est le
château renaissance par excellence s'il
n'en reste aujourd'hui qu'un tiers dont
la demeure de louis de brézé le mari de
diane de poitiers
on peut encore aisément imaginer ce
qu'il fut grâce entre autres à ceux
cryptoportique
il faut s'imaginer au xvième siècle avec
le bâtiment central là où il y avait les
appartements de diane qui reposait sur
ce cryptoportique donc il nous en manque
un petit bout puisque la niche qu'on
voit là était couverte par l ue yalda
l'âge tout le dallage était couvert et
diane de poitiers
descendez de ses appartements pour se
rendre dans le jardin en empruntant deux
escaliers en forme de croissant de lune
diane une plus que rennes une femme
d'exception qui se laver tous les jours
une rareté à l'époque une femme
d'affaires et d'amour qui fut la
maîtresse d'henri ii de 20 ans son cadet
ils étaient très amoureux d'elle elle
était omniprésente avec lui il faisait
du sport
elle était très cultivé très
intelligente lui aussi
dames d'henri diam s'entoure des
meilleurs artistes est un architecte au
sommet de son art philibert delorme
c'était une rupture complète et elle est
tombée sur cet architecte qui était
philibert delorme qui avait 32 ans un
lyonnais qui arrivait de rome elle lui a
dit voilà on va faire la première grande
maison de la renaissance en france quand
vous imaginez que ces engins ont été
sculptées dans des blocs de pierres pour
monter directement donc ça a été fait
dessus le type était à plat vente
et
et sculptés dans la pierre sur place
d'ailleurs on monte pas la pierre une
fois ce culte et si versailles est un
château solaire le château d'anet tu es
bien lunaire demeure princière retraite
d'amoureux henry 2 avait pour devise un
croissant de lune et le chiffre de diane
était composé de trois croissants entre
la ces genres de est urgent nous sommes
au coeur d'un magnifique vestibule avec
un immense escalier que l'on voit mais
que diane de poitiers n'a pas connu
puisqu'il a été créé en dix septième
siècle pourtant diane de poitiers a
connu bien d'autres pièces puisque ce
château a été créé pour elle enfin ça
c'est la légende
absolument d'abord cet escalier a été
créé par le duc de vendôme qui était
l'arrière petit fils de henri iv et de
gabrielle d'estrées et qui a fait des
modifications sous l'époque de louis xiv
où il a modifié considérablement le
château en créant cette extraordinaire
escaliers en plein milieu de la maison
alors il ya eu d'autres modifications
verra dans la salle des gardes et
d'autres choses qu'il a fait à
l'extérieur en particulier les jardins
il a fait venir le nôtre le jardinier
pour faire les jardins qui ont disparu
par la suite après la révolution puisque
c'est desjardins ont été abandonnés
pendant 60 ans la révolution a eu des
impacts ça a laissé des traces dans
l'histoire de la révolution a été
c'était assez barbare
parce que
en fait c'est peu de gens qui sont
arrivés de la ville de dreux ont dit
qu'ils étaient à peu près 18 personnes
et qui ont saisi le château qui était la
possession à l'époque du duc de
penthièvre qui était le fils du comte de
toulouse s'est embrasée certaine et
alors ils ont commencé par raser l'ale
centrale qui étaient là où henri ii avec
sa chambre et diane de poitiers avait
aussi sa chambre et une grande galerie
et puis ils ont de chaque côté de la
chapelle
ils ont aussi enlevé une partie de la
halle de droite est bien pour voir un
petit peu tout cela il ya des ingénieurs
qui crée des programmes avec
l'intelligence artificielle au service
du patrimoine et de l'histoire avec ce
reportage regarder tout de suite leur
jeunesse et le très haut niveau de
formation c'est leur caractéristique des
têtes ingénieurs pour la plupart cet
incubateur a pour mission la recherche
intransigeante des patrimoines un
véritable bouillon culturel la médiation
scientifique c'est encore au de
l'ingénierie de projet qui est mélange
de la recherche du numérique et donc où
on travaille avec tout ça pour concevoir
des projets numériques qui permettent de
valoriser les patrimoines auprès du
grand public
exemple le projet sur les pas de lona
par léonard de vinci qui propose de la
réalité virtuelle est un webdocumentaire
en 13 épisodes par exemple mais on a
aussi des projets qui parle de la
collégiale saint martin de tours qui va
être constituée en réalité virtuelle
parce qu'elle n'existe plus aujourd'hui
on va proposer aux tourangeaux de re
découvrir ce bâtiment il ya plein de
choses à faire avec le patron main dans
la région et donc on travaille là dessus
emmanuel barot 24 ans est ingénieur
informatique depuis trois ans il assure
la conception d'un documentaire
interactif et un jeu vidéo intitulé sur
les pas de léonard de vinci
yoann forte est lui aussi ingénieur
informatique à 23 ans il est chef de
projet médiation numérique
il dissèque un codec un croquis de
léonard de vinci
on a vraiment cherché à reconstruire
quelque chose de technologiquement
rigoureux en fait qui s'appuie vraiment
sur les codecs de léonard de vinci
ce qui m'a énormément intéressé en fait
c'est cette phase c'est cette faculté en
fait de leonardo s'inspirer de ce qu'ils
voyaient en extérieur pour concevoir ses
propres inventions en fait
au final c'est des choses qui dans la
nature semble très simple d'oiseaux qui
vole ça semble effectivement très simple
mais le reporter technologiquement pour
faire voler un homme ça devient toxique
beaucoup plus compliqué et lui a su
s'inspirer de ce qu'ils voyaient en
extérieur et recompose est donc
effectivement un génie ou non pour
produire son jean pour vous léonard de
vinci est il un génie
absolument et c'est un des plus grands
hommes génial qui a fait des inventions
incroyable il y avait une exposition à
venise l'autre jour il ya six mois
qu'ils montraient tous ces hélicoptères
machine et savez vous qu'il est à
l'origine des roues à aubes sur les
bateaux volume mais bien pour ce qu'ils
ne savent pas regardez ce reportage de
suite si ces personnes peuvent profiter
d'une balade sur la loire à bord de
cette embarcation
c'est grâce à leonard raccourci certes
mais devant s'y être même créer les
mécanismes des roues à aube ou sur les
bateaux
[Musique]
le bateau avance avec un système de
propulsion
l'epa l'emploi que l'on appelle aussi
les aubes servent à repousser l'eau afin
de permettre aux bateaux d'avancé elles
sont reliées entre elles par un essieu
juste ici en rouge c'est exactement le
même principe que lorsque mon âge de dos
crawlé lorsque l'homme appuie sur la
de gauche cela déclenche le
mécanisme central qui tournent dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre et
transmet son mouvement à l'anneau
intérieur lui donne l'information à
l'engrenage extérieur qui tourne dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
et donne la formation à l'essieu voilà
les roues à aubes tourner le bateau
glisse et léonard de vinci a une
nouvelle fois révolutionner lmnp
[Musique]
vous voyez actuellement le portrait de
diane de poitiers jean à quoi correspond
les critères de l'époque les critères de
l'époque elle était très très
particulière parce que elle était très
moderne elle était à la fois une femme
d'amour elle était une femme d'hygiène
se laver
ce que personne ne faisait à l'époque
tous les jours tous les jours avec de
l'eau froide qui n'avait pas reçu la
lune elle était une femme d'affaires
elle gérer elles mêmes sont ses affaires
et en plus de ça elle était une femme
sportive parce que les femmes de son
époque faisait pratiquement jamais de la
chasse
il montait pas à cheval avec les hommes
je crois que d'ici et elle chassait avec
le roi donc le roi était fasciné par
cette femme qui pourrait qu'une femme de
notre époque était bien différente
physiquement de sa rivale
alors qu'elle était la femme dans les 2
qui était la femme d'henri ii était
petit pas je lis un peu boulotte on dit
qu'elle avait perdu cet os et dents très
tôt et donc l est est ce que dirait ma
fille une bombe atomique
comparé à catherine de médicis est
évident pour vous de savoir qui est den
de poitiers n'est pas pour tout le monde
regarde et c'est diane de poitiers
vous posez une colle à la gelée su mais
je les oubliés chez sur sa batterie
tu avais pas du tout bon je vois qui
c'est mais bon ceci dit je réponds
discuter point une écrivaine le peintre
est une reine de france c'est 15 ans
votre comme ça c'était la cocotte de
chez plus que la femme de jeu par
ailleurs françois 1er il doit y avoir
quelque chose avec françois 1er diane de
poitiers son personnage historique
français qui doit venir de poitiers
j'imagine pas de poitiers bat pas de
potion magique qui s'annonce à pied je
dirais jon diat n'allait pas et
autrichiens n'ont autrichienne ni
autrichienne elle n'est belle n'habitez
pas à poitiers mal a passé la majorité
de sa vie ici à anet
nous sommes d'ailleurs dans sa chambre
enfin une reconstitution mais c'est bel
et bien son lit c'est bien les biens son
lit petit lit à mettre 40 de large et 1
c il est classé monument historique et
il ya toute sorte de symbole assez
extraordinaire autour de ce lit et un
tissu qui est le tissu d'origine du lit
c'est bien le tissu qui est classée un
nom tout jeu tous les lits sous le lit
il y avait deux lits de diane de
poitiers a été racheté par le prince
charles d'angleterre est le seul qui
reste en france c'est celui là il y à
des vestiges de son passage dans le
château en général comme une mèche de
cheveux expliquez-nous qu'elle senti
alors quand elle a été
le tombeau a été profanée au moment de
la révolution on a une des femmes du
village a profité en transportant le
corps de couper une mèche de cheveux de
diane ça on le verra avec la guide tout
à l'heure il ya des symboles dans cette
chambre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler de
ses symboles alors il ya beaucoup de
symboles d'abord il ya les dé l'aider
entrelacés et qui font en même temps h
donc c'est diane et henry donc il ya les
trois croissants de lune que vous
retrouvez pratiquement partout et
pourtant les tifos but la dynamique de
la lune dont qu'elle détestait la lune
mais ça a été véritablement son symbole
est donc là vous avez toutes sortes de
choses que correspondante au roi aussi
elle est restée à anet jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie après la mort de son amant merci
jean de yturbe d'avoir été notre invité
on va tout de suite direction la
chapelle funéraire
merci nous retrouvons notre guide du
château à nadège wanner bonjour nous en
juin devant la chapelle funéraire de
diane de poitiers rui une chapelle
qu'elle a commandés avant sa mort un
petit peu avant sa mort elle a commencé
à se préoccuper un petit peu de son
devenir post mortem et à la lancée à
l'est les travaux de construction de
cette chapelle est ce que c'est elle qui
a choisi ce magnifique tombeau non alors
on pensait que c'est plus sa fille ou
son petit fils la chapelle a été édifiée
en 1566 aller début des travaux fin et
elle a été consacrée en 1577 un tombeau
qui est noir et blanc de marbre à son
image à son image alors le marbre
peut-être pas voilà son image à elle
mais tout du moins noir et blanc les
couleurs préférées de diane de poitiers
il a été profanée ce tombeau pendant la
révolution française de commissaires
delà de la sûreté nationale de dreux
sont venus 1 jusqu'au tombeau
ils ont ouvert le sarcophage de diane de
poitiers avec la première intention de
récupérer le plomb 1 qui servait de
cercueils pour en faire des balles
patriote est donc là ils ont découvert
diane de poitiers
entouré de ses deux petites filles elle
était comment paraît-il qu'elle était
aussi belle que si elle avait été
enterré la veille
et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait de ces
housses de c'est là au bout d'une
dizaine de minutes les vêtements sont
partis en lambeaux folles et le corps de
diane de poitiers des petites filles ont
noirci nom qu'ils ont récupéré les
bijoux fins les envoyer à chartres en
train était chartrain ça c'est ça s'est
perdu et les corps ont été placés ont
été jetés dans une charrette à bras
devant la chapelle funéraire et là ils
ont été récupérés par des femmes du
village est enterré au cimetière d'anet
qui est devenu ce sarcophage lors ce
sarcophage il a été vendu villa servi
d'aujou de mangeoires alors pour les
cochons pour les chevaux dans un sachet
en fermiers des environs
oui et après coup théâtre en 2008
en 2008 une équipe pluridisciplinaire de
médecins légistes et de chercheurs sont
venus jusqu'au cimetière d'annette pour
relever les restes de diane de poitiers
là ils ont été analysés authentifié et
replacer dans son tombeau le 29 mai 2010
ils ont découvert des ossements
également des fragments résiduelle de 10
de tissus des composés qu'ils ont
analysé ils ont découvert un taux d'or
extrêmement élevé 25 250 fois supérieurs
à la normale
oui et on a compris que c'était diane de
poitiers pour quelle raison parce que
diane de poitiers consommer de l'or
potable c'était une rumeur qui circulait
sur diane de poitiers on a toujours
apparentes et de la rumeur jusqu'en 2008
et puis avec ce château d'or on s'est
aperçu que la rumeur était fondée et
qu'elle consommait de leurs potable pour
rester belle échelle d'autre part
peut-être pas le faire mais non la
société très très mauvaise a fragilisé
sa santé sa santé alors détruire ses
défenses immunitaires fragilisé ces eaux
a rendu ses cheveux très secs et
cassants et des chaussées une partie de
ses dents bon eh bien c'est pas une
bonne idée merci recours pour ce faisant
paris du salon merci je vous en prie
entre temps pour la petite histoire gens
de youtube le propriétaire nous a confié
que c'est bel et bien
diane de poitiers qui a construit qui a
fait construire ce château est le même
avec ses sous et que c'est une rumeur
corps et deux à dépenser à l' aider
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
renaissance au château d'anne est la
semaine prochaine
vous irez à valence et avec denis
gagnent et d'autres événements en centre
val de loire sont organisées pour
célébrer lé 500 ans de la renaissance au
hasard une exposition à mes seins sur
yèvre l accueil l accueil les
coire est lumineuse et colorée l art
situent les villes de la renaissance et
montrent leur évolution une déambulation
sur des musiques de la renaissance est
organisée demain à l'hôtel cabu musée
d'archéologie qu à orléans est toujours
demain le château de rivaux organise un
bal costumé sur la renaissance ça se
passe tout l'après midi et le soir même
seul vendredi prochain vous serez donc à
valence et avec denis guay née meyer
vous pouvez retrouver notre édition
spéciale châteaudun est sur notre site
internet c'est vdl point france 3 point
fr et sur le facebook live merci à toute
l'équipe aujourd'hui d'avoir fait les
éditions du 12/13 et du 19/20 belle
soirée à vous